okay so in that case uh thank you so
much
uh for being here and uh please go ahead
we'll go for
around let's shoot for 40 minutes
okay great right so today i'm going to
talk about
new work on linear time zero knowledge
succinct arguments
um and this is actually based on two
recent joint works
the first which appeared recently at tcc
2020 with alessandro casa
and jensgroth and the second which is
just about as brand new and fresh as
it's possible to be
appeared on eprint uh yesterday i think
and that's joint work with alessandro
kiesa and
sichulu
okay so we're in the setting of
efficient zero knowledge arguments for
np
and in this setting approval wants to
convince a verifier
that a statement from some language is
true so for example that
you know an n-gate arithmetic circuit
over a finite field
is satisfiable and we can ask ourselves
the question
what are the best possible efficiency
parameters that you could achieve
from such a zero-knowledge protocol
so if the circuit has n gates and it's
over a finite field f
then maybe the best that we could hope
for for the prover and the verifier
is a linear number of field operations
relative to the size of the circuit
i mean certainly both the prover and the
verified they do have to read the
circuit
before they can go through this protocol
so that seems reasonable
and then we could hope for just a poly
logarithmic number of bits communicated
between the prover and verifier
so is this the best possible well you
know maybe
if we introduce an indexer to
pre-process the arithmetic circuit
for the verify so that the verifier
doesn't even have to read it
maybe we could hope to do even better
and we could go for
poly logarithmic verification time for
example with the same nice
linear prover time and like nice poly
logarithmic
communication complexity so in some
sense you might consider efficiency
parameters like this
a holy grail for efficient zero
knowledge arguments
now just to be very clear and explicit
about it
let's talk about what counts as linear
time for the prover
and the indexer so the original
computation that we'll deal with
in this talk is the computation of an
n-gate arithmetic circuit
over a finite field as we've seen and
you can evaluate the entire circuit
using
n field operations so what kind of
prover and index of computation should
we allow
um for linear time well
anything with like a small logarithmic
factor or any like small multiplicative
dependence on the security parameter
that's going to be completely disallowed
um we don't want that
but we would allow something which is
you know a constant times
the number of gates in the circuit uh
maybe with a small additive dependence
on the security parameter
now that would be okay so that's what
counts as linear time for the purposes
of this talk
so unfortunately lots of prior works
failed to achieve
you know this really really strong
requirement
from zero knowledge arguments and the
main reason for this is because they use
techniques like
fast fourier transforms to perform like
polynomial multiplications as part of
the proof
or to you know compute encodings of the
witness using
read solomon codes and this just adds an
extra
logarithmic overhead into the prover
time or
alternatively there are plenty of works
which are using algebraic commitments
like pedestal commitments
and initially they look like they might
be linear time
but actually to compute a commitment to
a linear number of values
is a linear number of exponentiations in
some kind of cryptographic group
and then that gives you a lambda
overhead when you actually examine that
cost and measure it in terms of
finite field operations so anything that
uses fast fourier transforms
or the most popular algebraic
commitments like pedestrian commitments
is just completely ruled out if we want
this type of result
and there are lots and lots of you know
really exciting like really
really good concretely efficient um
existing works which
which which just falls short of this
this holy grail
um and you know lots of them have
actually eliminated the fast fourier
transforms completely
but they still rely on these
cryptographic commitments um
even though they achieve like excellent
proof size and like you know really good
proof and verification time and practice
if we want to achieve this holy grail
type result then for sure we need to
throw away the algebraic commitments
and ffts um so what should we do
well there is somewhere we can start
from there was a result in 2017 which
actually did produce
cryptographic arguments with a linear
time improver and
a linear time indexer and that's based
on
you know first producing an information
theoretic protocol
an interactive oracle proof which has
similar nice linear time properties
and then there's this hashing strategy
whereby all the elements in this
information theoretic proof
are kind of hashed up into a merkle tree
and then this gives rise to a
cryptographic argument with with similar
efficiency properties
um so the key point here is that the
hash functions used
for this transformation are a bit
special so hashing a linear number of
field elements
is actually at most a linear number of
field operations
so this hashing strategy is really good
unfortunately
we don't really get the result that we
want because the underlying iop has
a verified complexity and a query
complexity which is still a square root
in the circuit size unfortunately
so to achieve our holy grail the
question becomes
can we construct linear time iops with
better query complexity
and you know of course better
verification time
so now on to our results and
it turns out that the answer is yes so
over these two recent works in the in
the first work
we actually managed to get an iop which
has better verifier and query complexity
so
any sub-linear value in the in the size
of the arithmetic circuit
which is really good but we didn't
manage to get any zero knowledge
properties in that work
then in the second follow-up work we
actually managed to shrink down the
verified complexity and the query
complexity
to poly logarithmic and logarithmic and
really get the zero knowledge property
so this is great this kind of gives us
the holy grail that we that we always
wanted
if we follow the same hashing strategy
then we get some cryptographic arguments
which have
uh you know exactly the same
corresponding efficiency properties
and zero knowledge properties so yeah
fantastic
we're all done well
there are still some there are still
some you know some small things that
we'd like to improve about this result
um which uh which are pretty interesting
in themselves so
um the i think the main caveat that we
have here is that
the argument works over you know large
finite fields which have
at least big omega of n elements so um
i'd say this question of linear time
arguments is still open
for really small finite fields like
constant size fields
boolean fields and so on the other thing
is that the verify complexity in the
query complexity is still poly
logarithmic and
logarithmic maybe we could also aim for
a constant number of queries
in the future or like try and shave off
polynomial factors from
the poly logarithmic verification but
still this is really cool
um this is this is kind of what we
always wanted
so let's see a bit about how those
results came about
um so firstly we should talk about what
interactive oracle proofs actually are
um interactive oracle proofs
are like interactive protocols between
approver and a verifier in which the
prover sends these proof oracles to the
verifier
and instead of completely reading the
messages
as in a normal interactive proof the
verify just has query access to the
proof oracles
and then the proven verifier interact
over several rounds
and then at any point the verifier can
make different queries to the proof
oracles
and so we can consider queries from
different classes
so the three classes that we consider in
these two works are
point queries now these are pretty easy
in the point query model the verifier
just looks at individual entries
of the provers proof articles another
one which is important for us
is the class of tensor queries in which
the verifier can ask for
structured linear combinations of the
messages in the proof oracle
using this tensor product to get the
linear combination and these are like a
subclass of
the class of linear queries which has
been considered elsewhere
so what happens in the first paper
is that we use an approach where we
start off with
a tensor query iop and then we use
an interesting code based compiler which
takes as input also a linear error
correcting code
and through this transformation we
convert the tensor query iop
into a point query iop with subliner
query complexity
and verified complexity
and the the main part of the codebase
compiler is this
uh this sublinear consistency test you
know with the right
query complexity and verify complexity
now let's take a look inside some of
those components
so the the tensor query iop that
the best tensor query iop that we can
that we can come up with at the moment
um it works for arithmetic circuit
satisfiability
over fields of this size and we have a
linear time prover
linear time indexer subliner verifier
and a constant query complexity with
these tensor queries
so using our codebase compiler we'll be
able to convert this
into the sublinear point query iop of um
of that first paper that i mentioned
so the thing to note here is that the
tensor query iop we started off with
is yeah well it just has a constant
number of queries
and then things became slightly worse um
once we moved to this uh this sublinear
regime with the point query iop um we
have a sub linear number of queries
there
and in some sense you know what what's
going on here is that we started off
with like a powerful
query class of tensor queries and then
we've like
we've switched over to um to this weak
class of point queries so
the verifier needs to do more work to
check that
tensor queries were simulated properly
we'll see that in a bit more detail
later
we can also take a look inside our
codebase compiler so there
these compilers this compiler is not
just useful for
for our main result because it takes a
tensor query iop
and then it produces a point query iop
by combining that tensor query iop with
like any linear code
so like the overheads of the point query
iop that you get in the end
depend on like the the encoding time and
uh and the rate and other properties of
the error correcting code
in particular if we choose like a linear
time incredible code as
as the input then the compiler is going
to preserve the prover and indexer
complexity
so using linear time encodable codes is
going to be really useful
for achieving our main results also
we'll see exactly what this means later
but if the error correcting code c
has some zero knowledge properties then
it turns out that this compiler will
also preserve
any zero knowledge properties of the
underlying tensor query iop
okay but that compiler is only just the
compiler that i've stated here is only
just good enough
to to achieve the sublinear result in
our in our first paper
and it doesn't get you all the way to
this holy grail
so what if you want poly logarithmic
proof size and verification
uh you need to do something a bit more
complicated there so
instead of taking the original
consistency test as is
um we actually mess around with it a bit
and come up with something that's more
efficient so
we actually apply proof composition
techniques to some of the results in the
first paper to improve the consistency
test
and this will give us a final point
query iop with
much better verification costs and much
lower query complexity
um then in order to add zero knowledge
to our final result
we need to add zero knowledge first to
the the tensor query iop
which turns out to be sort of a standard
exercise and
we also need to add zero knowledge to
the linear error correcting codes that
we use which turns out to be really
interesting
um so in this talk i hope to go over
some more of the details of the the code
based compiler in particular
and the zero knowledge codes
there are loads and loads of techniques
related to our work so in particular
like it's really closely related to
prior works on linear time interactive
proofs um
different holographic arguments
and and then especially
different works on code-based iops so
the code-based iops here
um they either give like um
interesting you know general code-based
arguments for
mp or like interesting proximity tests
for for different codes
or um you know the one of them in this
red circle is a linear time argument
so perhaps the most closely related one
is this rr20 work
and
that's actually that's actually the work
that ron talked about on monday
so that that piece of work has a very
similar structure to our own
um the main difference being that uh ron
is trying to be a master of
space complexity in that work and um in
this work we're trying to um
you know really really focus on time
complexity of the proof and verifier
okay so before i before i talk
um in more detail about any of the
techniques inside the papers
um i think this would be a good time to
like uh
pause and uh pause and ask questions
answer questions i'm sorry
are there any questions
i can see that benedict unmuted himself
but he hasn't said anything yet so
maybe let me ask a quick question do you
have an estimate of the
duplicative constant in the prover's
running time
um no we we don't actually have an
estimate of that
um i expect that the the main factor to
consider that
is um is from the from the error
correcting codes so
there'll be some constant associated
with um the encoding time of the error
correcting code
um we're going to use tensor codes so
we'll end up taking
you know um taking different functions
of that
that constant to get to the tensor
product so um
yeah i'd say that's the main factor in
determining the constant but we haven't
thought about
um you know exactly what it might be
concretely
and more broadly do you do you feel like
this approach can be attractive from a
concrete efficiency viewpoint compared
to the competition
yeah i think so potentially um at least
some parts of it so
um i think the interesting thing about
the code based compiler
is that it can take any error correcting
code as input
so um in particular if you were able to
find some some really nice
fast code construction then
potentially you could get something
really efficient um there are lots of
different parameters that you could play
with
um i think more of a barrier to concrete
efficiency is maybe
um the proof composition techniques that
we used later but
yeah certainly i think there are lots of
parameters to to play around with
and even if you wanted to use um read
solomon codes in the compiler and like
lose the linear time i think um
that would still be interesting
practical things to investigate from
this approach
okay thank you uh jonathan i have a
question too
hi yeah um so about the zero knowledge
aspect i'm just curious if
if you take uh say your first succinct
argument um and then compose that with
the non-succinct nisk
or yeah if you're aiming for
non-interactive wouldn't that give you
also zero knowledge
um yeah that's right um so that would be
that would be an easy way to do it i
suppose um i think um
the reason why we ended up investigating
maybe some some interesting questions
about our correcting codes was um
we really wanted to do all the hard work
information theoretically in the iop
model
um and get a really nice zero knowledge
um
uh point query iop with all the right
properties before turning it into
into an argument so so yeah i agree with
you i think
i think it you know it would be easier
and you wouldn't have to consider some
of these questions if um
you went straight to the argument level
yeah so continuing on
ron's question so if you take the asia
crypt 17 paper what is the time if
if the verifier that runs in square root
in time then why not use
proof composition to go all the way
um so
let's see um that's a good question
actually
um it's not it's not necessarily clear
to me that um that that approach
wouldn't work and um
and give you something just um i think
i think uh you know at some points when
writing these papers
um it wasn't necessarily clear that
that you know there were good enough
ingredients to you know for like the
the nrip to use for proof composition
that would give you something which
which was still linear time in the end
actually it's nice to
to use this sublinear point query iop
for proof composition because
you know regardless of the like the
polynomial efficiency of
what you compose with you can kind of
shrink down um
shrink down the sublinear complexity
before composition and then you don't
have to worry about the exact
polynomials involved in particular maybe
to to add to that
the inner proof system would have to
have
a prover that is reasonably subquadratic
in order to compose it with the uh
agency 2017 paper and
it has to be like uh not just
a pcp or lp but as to be a pcp of
proximity or iop of proximity
and at least my personal belief is such
a thing exists but i don't think an
analysis of it has been done
or at least we didn't do it in in the
bcgt 13 paper
we only did the non-proximity part so
kind of going to like a greater
sublinear er
starting from a greater subliner sort of
removes this uh this worry of you know
do i have a good enough
inner component like jonathan said um
that's that's one point and regarding
your point about composition at the
argument level
you know it's primarily a question of
making a black box result like
with black box cryptography it's um
it's it's pretty i don't know
i find it personally complicated to keep
track of are we really
or are we not linear when you start like
dealing with like krypton crypto
uh yeah so
right so your result makes the black box
use of the underlying
crypto primitive so this distinguishes
it at least with a naive way of doing
the composition
at least at the computational level so
yeah that's a good answer
thanks
okay great so um any more any more
questions or um
is it time to go on and
can you guys hear me an hour
yeah yeah we are at least i am hearing
you so go ahead
oh then well my question is just
but maybe if it's time to answer then
you can answer it at the end but it's
regarding the
field size so you said the field size
has to be
on the order of the size of the
statement is that correct
that's right yeah so um do you think
that's inherent or
what my two questions are a whether you
think that's inherent and b
whether you think that you can like uh
maybe
pack uh at least like maybe binary
operations right
or something like that into a large
field and achieve something
that way right yeah that's um
that's a very good question um
yeah at the moment i i do think that
it's inherent so um
the the reason that we we have to use
fields of that size is because
um at some point during the proof we're
using the the schwarzepaler
and polynomials of degree of n
and so um at the moment for various
holographic parts of the argument um
i i don't see a way to to remove those
and
then the issue with you know packing
many many different field operations
into like single operations in a field
extension element
is um you know there's some there's some
like small logarithmic overhead
um in the cost of doing like a field
extension operation
so if you can't you can't do
you can't even do too many field
extension operations so um i think it
becomes extremely
tricky so if you if you try to implement
a binary
field or binary circuit then it would be
actually the cos
would be actually n squared or at least
n squared
because you're paying of n for the field
and um
yeah that's right so um i think if you
if you remove the the holographic
requirement so if you
if you stop doing the pre-processing and
you go back to a linear verification
time
um then actually the bottleneck comes
from comes from a different place in the
proof
and like polynomials of much lower
degree um logarithmic in
in n so that's obviously much better but
it still doesn't tell you anything about
constant size fields so i think yeah i
think
i think it'd be really really
interesting um
and probably quite difficult to get into
constant size fields
jonathan a quick question um so you
mentioned that this
in this work you're primarily concerned
with time complexity not space
complexity but
the technique still laminable to like a
streaming style prover where you don't
need to keep the entire
for example trace in memory necessarily
or as i guess if you're working the
circuit model you might need to
but i guess you can still like write it
on disk and then read it back or you
need to have the entire thing in memory
at all times
let's see um that's that's not actually
something i've considered
uh so far um i think that would be a
pretty
pretty interesting research direction to
investigate though
okay cool thanks
okay great well maybe at this point i'll
go on and i'll tell you a bit about
some of the techniques inside our result
so first i'm just going to say just a
little just very little about
the tensor query iops
so the main point is that it's very very
easy to get hold of a tensor query iop
um we have a lot of protocols like the
sumcheck protocol
which are based on um the verifier
having
point query access to the load degree
extension
of the prover's witness so we can run a
subject protocol
we know that this can be done in linear
time
so this is a good start and then the
main observation
that you need here um which comes from
uh you know ron's talk and
uh was mentioned in this work on monday
is that actually
evaluations of the loader extension can
be can be phrased as tensor queries
so the sum check essentially gives you a
tensor iop
and if you want to see that more
concretely you can consider this
horrible expression here so
um any low degree extension evaluation
could be written
as a as a tensor query to the witness
so if this expression scares you don't
worry you don't have to think about it
too much
but the main point is that since the sum
check protocol
already so easily gives you a tensor rop
and the subcheck protocol can can
already be computed in linear time and
deals with all kinds of np relations
um it's uh it's actually fairly easy to
get hold of
you know good tensor query iops we did
have to do some serious work in the
paper
in the first paper to um to come up with
holographic tensor query iop
um but there's lots of there's lots of
prior work to draw on this
in this area
but you know perhaps a more interesting
part of our work
is um is the code based compiler
techniques
which i'll talk about now
so we're going to start with tensor
query iop
so the proof is going to send different
tensor op proof oracles to the verifier
who's going to make tensor queries to
those we want to convert this
into a point query iop
so the way we're going to do that is
we're going to kind of
simulate what happened in the tensor
query iop so
every time instead of sending the tensor
iop proof message that they were going
to send
the prover sends an encoding of that
message
and then the verifier can now make point
queries to those so
whenever the verifier would have asked a
tensor query to
to one of the oracles they just send
this query straight to the approver
who responds with the the answer to that
tensor query
okay and so
we still need to add some extra checks
at the end of this uh kind of simulation
process for the tensor iop
we need to check whether the approver
you know really sent like correctly
encoded oracles which are like
good encodings of um of proof messages
and now that the prover has the freedom
to to answer the tensor queries by
themself
um we also need to check whether the
query answers are consistent with all of
the
encoded oracles so here we want to
choose
encodings which um preserve linear time
and have like good proximity
and consistency tests
so i think um i think an interesting
thing to note here is that um
so if you if you look back at how the
tensor query iop was produced
um this was you know you can easily
produce tensor tensor query iops based
on these low degree extensions which are
like one type
of one type of encoding and then
like specifically here where you know
we're trying to to switch to another
type of encoding so as well as the
tensorquery iop
to point query iop you know viewpoint
compiling from one ib to another
there's also this code switching
viewpoint um which sort of comes from
this uh this rr20 paper that i've i've
mentioned a couple of times
all right so the coding the
the encoding scheme that we actually use
is going to be
uh tensor code
and the tensor code is based on some
some well base code c and it turns out
that our code based compiler it doesn't
really need
any special properties from from c in
order to get soundness
the code c just needs to be linear we do
need a bit more from zero knowledge and
and we'll get to that later
um and most importantly for us
is that the the tensor code is
incredible in linear time
if the base code c is encodable in
linear time as well
and we've got examples of linear time
encodable codes like um
spielman codes or druka shy codes
which we can use as part of our tensor
product codes
and come up with like a linear time
encodable construction
so i'm about to talk about how the um
how the consistency test works um are
there any questions or sort of
um tensor coded tensor codes or like um
the way that the tensor query iop
is simulated
okay great so i'll talk about how the uh
the consistency test works
so we've got uh a tensor query answer um
the answer to some
some query on um on like a proof oracle
pie
and we've also got the tensor encoding
of the proof oracle pi
um and in order to check consistency
between the two
we need to know how they're connected so
of course they're connected by
by the oracle that was um that was
queried and encoded um
but we need to look a bit more closely
so
first we're going to see like we're
going to see a different way of
computing uh
tensor queries from the proof oracle pi
so for this we're going to define a
folding operation
so if we have like three arrays like a1
a2 and a3
you can fold with the linear combination
v1 v2 v3
just by using the v's to like take a
linear combination of the a's
so when you have this folding operation
you can view like the computation of a
tensor query
as like repeated folding so we like
first fold by
one component of the tense query then we
fold by the next component
and then we fold by by the last
component and this will give
this is like a sequential way of
computing the answer to a tensor query
on the tensor irp proof data
okay so we can get between the tensor
query answer and the original tensorip
proof oracle
through this folding procedure
now we have to ask like how are the
tensor codings computed
so we can we can build a bridge between
the two
so you can you can phrase the um the
computation of these tensor encodings
um through these partial encodings so if
i want to produce
some tensor encodings i could encode all
of these arrays on the slide like
horizontally first
using the base code c then i could
encode everything vertically
and this would give me the the tensor
code
so we know that by sequential encoding
we can get from the proof oracle to the
tensor code word
okay so in order to check consistency
we're going to fill in this diagram a
bit diagonally
by encoding and folding some of the
different components
and the idea behind our consistency test
is we want to check consistency at each
stage
in this diagonal direction
now the way that we can do this is by
noting that the folding operations and
these partial encoding operations
actually commute and um and so what the
verifier would want to check
is that these these messages on the
diagonal
so that when you when you fold and code
them in the right way these actually
collide and um they give equal values
so the proof is the proof is going to
send um
uh these diagonal messages as um as
their
their point query proof oracles to
enable a consistency test
the verifier wants to check that all of
these values are equal on
folding and encoding but we need to do
this using a small number of queries
and with like a low verification cost so
actually the verifier just queries these
um these stripes
of um all the different proof oracles
and then
the distance properties of the error
correcting code actually guarantee that
um
checking only a few positions is enough
to to find any inconsistencies
so by checking um by checking along the
diagonal
at sort of each folding and encoding
step we can check
consistency between like the encoded
proof message
and um and the final um like tensor
query answer
so um so one thing i want to say here is
that um
um there's you know we had this
we we talked about this nice um this
nice rr20 result which is about
um producing uh interactive oracle
proofs with a very low rate
um and we have this we have this work
too which is um
based on producing interactive oracle
proofs with with linear time
um so those are both um those are both
of the flavor of like
you know complexity preserving iop
results and they
they both use tensor encodings in this
very important way
um so i think it'd be really interesting
to know if there are any other
approaches for producing
iops or any other interesting approaches
for producing arguments
which sort of don't go through um
you know these these compiler techniques
between different iops
and don't use any properties of tensor
codes
all right so let's very quickly take a
look at the
the prover complexity of this approach
so
um if we have if we have like uh
n elements of tensor iop proof data
then it takes you know o of n
field operations to actually fold those
up
and uh you know similarly if we use like
good linear time encodable codes
then the the costs of the cost of
encoding
um the the proof messages to get the
tensor code words
at the top of the diagram are also going
to be linear um it says little o of n
but that's actually a typo it should be
big o of n
just there
now to compute the the other proof
messages used as part of the tensor ip
now at this point we're already dealing
with like folded up tensor iop proof
data
which has size little o of n so all of
the folding
and encoding operations that the prover
does here
those actually all have a sub-linear
cost so
um none of these operations actually
exceed any linear costs so
if we start off with like a linear time
tensor query iop
we don't break anything using this
transformation
as for the verified complexity since the
verifier only looks at these stripes
so in the running in in the kind of
picture that we've got on the board now
um for this example uh the verification
cost and the query complexity will be
o of cube root of n because the verifier
only looks up
only ever looks at like one dimension of
these arrays
okay um so that was some information on
the the code based compiler um
are there any that well in particular
that that's the that's the code based
compiler that would give the
the sublinear uh result with the
subliner verification costs
and sublinear query complexity um are
there any questions about the different
parts of this
this result or how that works
all right well if there are no questions
on on that bit
then um i think next i was i was
actually going to talk about proof
composition techniques
and and how you how you reduce
the the query complexity and the
verified complexity
of this consistency test that we just
described
actually since you can use since you can
view most of the components
you know for the proof composition as a
black box and um
these techniques are like relatively
standard compared to the other
techniques in the paper
i'm actually going to skip straight to
the zero knowledge codes
part of the talk and talk about how we
we get zero knowledge in our final
construction
because i think well personally for me
that was that was definitely the most
interesting part of our paper
okay so zero knowledge codes
okay so we're going to be using these uh
these tensor encodings to
encode all of this tensor iop proof data
and
the verifier is going to make point
queries to
you know different individual entries of
these these tensor code words as part of
point query iop and we need to make sure
that the verifies queries don't leak any
information
about the witness so
as well as having nice linear time
properties and nice like distance
properties
our tensor codes also need to have some
zero knowledge properties
okay unfortunately um you know this
isn't guaranteed from the beginning
if you if you think about encoding a
message using an error correcting code a
linear error correcting code
well every entry of the codeword is
actually a sum
of message elements so whichever
codeword entry
the verifier looks at they're going to
learn something about the individual
message they're going to learn one of
these linear
combinations of of message elements
so the way to try and fix this is to
choose some elements of the message
uniformly at random you know add some
encoding randomness to the end of the
message
now if the verifier queries like for
example the first three entries of a
codeword
then you know as long as the verifier
can't sort of add and subtract and
take linear combinations or do different
operations on these codeword entries
they'll never be able to get rid of some
of these elements of encoding randomness
and they won't be able to learn anything
about the
the original message okay
so um so far so good
so what we need to do is um is find a
way to
um to study the the zero knowledge
properties of codes
based on based on the structure of the
codes and
you know the the amount of encoding
randomness that we want to use
and we need to make sure that um
that is also going to work for tensor
encoding schemes
so one technique that we actually use on
our paper
is to define the zero knowledge property
of codes algebraically so
if i write if i write the code word as
the the product of like uh some kind of
generator matrix multiplied by
a message and some encoding randomness
we can ask like
what property of the generator matrix is
it like what property of the code
actually gives you
um a zero knowledge property so that
code words don't leak any information
and if we can understand this for simple
codes this will be a start to
to understanding something about uh
tensor codes and their zero knowledge
properties
so we're going to split the generator
matrix into one part that deals with the
message
and one part that deals with the
encoding randomness
okay and then we can rewrite
the computation of the code word like
this with a message bar
and like this random mask and now if the
verifier queries the first three entries
now the reason that it wasn't possible
for um for the verifier to to eliminate
the encoding randomness
from these first three entries of the
code word was because
actually no non-zero linear combination
of the first three rows of this
randomness part
um will give you zero um so
some property of this the you know the
the row space of like the randomness
part of
of this matrix
and actually this property has been
studied before so in 2016
uh mo vice actually showed that no
weight be
linear combination of of rows of this
randomness part
gives zero if if that's the case then
up to b queries to the codeword leaks no
information about the underlying message
so this is good this is interesting um
now we do sharpen things up a bit in our
paper so um
um the important thing here was to
consider like linear combinations of the
rows of the randomness part of the
matrix
and ask whether those are equal to zero
or not so
if we define the solution space for this
linear equation
like all the linear combinations that
give zero um we call that like dc
then we know that every element of dc is
some kind of strategy which the verifier
can use
to cancel the encoding randomness from
like codeword entries that they see
and learn something about the the
underlying message
um so based on this characterization
um we can we can understand um
we can understand sort of zero knowledge
conditions for codewords a little bit
better
so um if this space dc has like minimum
distance b plus one
then at most um
up to and almost like b queries of the
codeword actually look uniformly random
um so this is a stronger property than
before um
where we just knew that up to b queries
like no information
and i think it's pretty interesting also
to know that um you know any b plus one
queries
um are kind of not uniformly random
and uh you know maybe they might leak
some information um
so by by moving to the stronger property
of like uniform randomness and
uh looking at things in more detail we
were able to like uh strengthen
um this condition from 2016 to like a
nice equivalence and then we have like
this is about uniformly random entries
of codewords we have like similar
results for
um the zero knowledge property of codes
where entries don't leak any information
um so i think now now would be a good
time to
to pause and maybe answer questions
about this um
and next i'll go on to talk about the
zero knowledge properties of tensor
codes
oh well this i mean uh yeah this is the
this is the coolest part of the paper
i would absolutely love to to answer
questions about it so
um i'm gonna persist just for just for
like 20 more seconds just in case
there's
there's a question from an enthusiast
okay cool well um i guess um
you know before i move on i would just
say that you know one of the reasons i
find this
this result so cool was um you know
before i didn't really know
generally know say like based on a
particular linear code like um
how to how to compute something about
about zero knowledge properties um
the reason i really like this
characterization is because um
you know now in principle like given the
generator matrix for some code
i can actually like concretely compute
its um
its zero knowledge band which is not
something i knew how to do before
um and i can do that using like um you
know shortest code word algorithms and
you know stuff from lattice script
analysis and
i found that crossover kind of really
interesting
um let me go and talk about uh tensor
products of zero knowledge codes
so the the first question here is um if
we want to encode a message using a
tensor code
how do we add the randomness to the to
the message i mean
um i think uh you know when i first
thought about this
um this this wasn't obvious at all to me
like um
how should you make a how should you add
randomness to a message to make a tensor
code hiding
any ideas
encode some randomness with the message
oh yeah that's that's right yeah um i
guess the question is uh sort of
which format uh which format do you want
to use like uh
where in this blue square do you want to
place the randomness
i guess maybe around the edge
yeah that's it yeah so um yeah i mean
in one dimension we have like a message
which is in a line and then we kind of
extend the line using some extra
randomness
then in two dimensions we have a message
which is a square and then we just kind
of
extend with randomness in a square so um
so this is um this is a good way to to
get a zero knowledge property from uh
from tensor codes um the nice thing
about using this method is that
you know we're still using the original
encoding algorithm for the tensor code
as a black box so um
you know even though the the first paper
the subliner paper using tensor codes um
didn't achieve any zero knowledge
property um because we could
um add the randomness in this way and we
didn't interfere with
the structure of the tensor codes we
could use loads of results from the
first paper
as a black box when trying to get zero
knowledge
um so that was really good
um now in order to understand like the
the query bound
for um for the the tensor product code
um
so we have this space dc which tells you
something about like how many entries of
the
um the base code word don't leak any
information we need to understand
somehow this space uh
d of c cross c so if you visualize
um if you visualize like the structure
of
um of of this space dc
um as part of a line like intersecting
with um
with the original code um
you know so we have this space uh dc
which tells us something about the zero
knowledge properties of the base code c
now um one way to try and understand the
zero knowledge property of the the
tensor product
is to actually like draw a corresponding
picture in two dimensions for the tensor
code
cross secrecy so it turns out that like
um
you can you can like nicely characterize
the the shape of this space
you know for the tensor product code um
in terms of like the
space for the for the base code um
so since we can draw this picture um
um which tells you that you know d of c
cross c is expressed as like um
the tensor product of maybe you know um
um the the dual code of c like tensor
product with something else and
something else we were able to get sort
of
an exact expression um in terms of
linear spaces for this uh space
d of c cross c and then this lets us
prove something about the query bounds
of the the tensor product code so
we're able to show that if um b queries
to the base code look uniformly random
well we have this equivalence condition
which give us like bounds on
the minimum distance of this space d of
um we could show that um the
the associated like tensor product space
had like the same minimum distance
and so then up to b queries to the the
tensor code also look uniformly random
so using these kinds of techniques we
could show that yeah also the tensor
product code is a zero knowledge code if
the base code is
um we have similar results for like
tensor products under zero knowledge
and um in the paper you can also see um
a couple of interesting constructions of
linear time encodable base codes to use
to get our construction so
linear time and zero knowledge and um
they're very useful in achieving
our main result
you want them to jump jump in here let's
try to i mean i'll let you run a few
more minutes because there were
questions along the way
but let's try to wrap up in the next say
two or three minutes
sure okay so um that actually brings me
to my conclusion anyway
um so let me summarize the results that
we have um
in in these two works in the first work
we constructed
a linear time computable iop
point query iop which had any sub-linear
verification complexity
and any sublinear query complexity but
didn't have any zero knowledge property
in the second piece of work we improved
the verified complexity to poly
logarithmic
and the query complexity to logarithmic
as well as adding the zero knowledge
property
and then using this hashing strategy
that we talked about with these special
hash functions
gives you associated linear time
arguments
with like uh the same kind of complexity
parameters
um and this is sort of exactly what we
wanted
for a type of holy grail result
described at the start
i think the main open question that's
left is to do something for
smaller fields which have little of n
elements because
you know there as as i discussed like in
answering benedict's question
uh some of the techniques we were using
just just break down mostly due to
um the use of the schwarzer dilemma with
with high degree polynomials
so that's like the main the main open
problem that i think uh
you know remains from this work um
so thank you very much for listening um
here again are the two links to two
pieces of work and uh i'm happy to take
any more questions about
our results
um thank you so much jonathan uh before
people drop off let me just mention
there are uh
two more to two more and last uh talks
in the afternoon
starting at noon california time uh
jacob laschner is giving a talk uh
followed by a
jing chan uh yeah so
please come back and uh
but otherwise you know we have a few
more minutes now in case there are more
questions for jonathan
and it probably is a good time to do so
um i have a follow-up question to my
previous question that's okay
sure um so i was asking about kind of
composing with another
in order to obtain zero knowledge
composing with say nisk or something
like that and
i guess you were saying uh you'd rather
not do that because you wanted to keep
things
information theoretic which makes sense
but so so why not compose with uh
zero knowledge pcpp or iop or something
like that
um that's that's also an option
um i guess i guess the question is then
do we have any do we have any sort of
off-the-shelf suitable
zero-knowledge iopps or pcbs with
constant query complexity you know
potentially that would work um
it was convenient to to use this um this
this kind of off-the-shelf result we had
which uh which didn't have any zero
knowledge
um actually um we we did investigate
this approach and um
also in our paper um we sort of we sort
of studied very carefully um you know
facts about the uh
the zero knowledge properties of um
you know iopps and uh under composition
like what happens when you
robustify with the zero knowledge code
and stuff like that so um
although we didn't go down this path um
we did investigate like um
you know some of the some of the like
formal zero knowledge properties like um
that would that would stand you in good
stead if you if you did try to follow
that alternative path
but so you eventually get if i'm not
mistaken you get
poly logarithmic query complexity so
actually
as you know pcp with with like a pi
logarithmic
query it would suffice is that right
um zero knowledge
yeah um that's actually i guess that's
um
i guess there's a technical point there
so um um
you know strictly strictly speaking we
we have this uh consistency test which
is used in our compiler which has like
sublinear
query complexity and verify complexity
um
and we apply proof composition to that
um there are some other sort of there's
there's some other logarithmic
communication costs which are not part
of that uh consistency test so
i think if you wanted to try and get
like a constant query complexity um
you could try doing proof composition on
like um the whole proof system rather
than just this
consistency test part and then you might
see something a bit bit different as
well
okay thanks
does the folding operation affect zero
knowledge like uh do i have to do
something to
stop this from leaking information all
right so
um so so what we actually do is
um as part of the the tensor the tensor
query
iop um and uh somewhere in the code
based compiler
um we produce these we produce these big
masks
um so every time we have like a tensor
iop proof message
um we compute like a random mask of the
the same size
um and then using these masks we kind of
we kind of run the the compiler and the
consistency test
on values which have already been masked
so um
um so the values which are being folded
up are these these values which have
already been masked so um
uh like the the smaller arrays that that
i was showing in the slide like um
lower down in the diagram um they don't
leak any information at all because
they're kind of like folded up
things which have already been masked um
it only sort of matters at the top so
when you want to make a query to the
original masked
so so the biggest masked message but
this is a sum of for like um
a tensor iop proof message and like a
and like a mask so
you only have to worry about things at
the very top and then um that
information is protected by um
by by the tensor encodings
an interesting point related to masks is
has to do with rate
so unlike uh ron's work
where you can use these tensors in a
very helpful way to get the rate close
to one
provided that the also the code you
start work
start with has really really good rate
um just because we have these masks
flying around to mask uh
you know this and that query these are
extra code words are being sent that
sort of are on top of the encoding of
the kind of computation
and so these by themselves already they
give you
a it's a rate that is bounded uh
away from one in fact quite away from
one
um now like other applications of zero
knowledge probably they can be
randomized if you can
very carefully sort of sprinkle
randomness
in a white box way through the
corresponding protocols this like
something similar can be done with some
check and gkr
right so but they're achieving
simultaneously kind of zero knowledge
linear time
and rate close to one i think that's
also another question
uh because it kind of rates your
knowledge their kind of intention there
uh whenever you want to mask blind
things
you want to send extra code words but
rate close to one prevents you from
doing that
so you have to kind of do randomize
things
it's a nice question there
if you follow the kind of idea of
composing with the zero knowledge
pcpp or iopp say you start off with
if you had a something that was not zero
knowledge with a linear time
prover and uh succinct proof
and then you compose with uh
a zero knowledge pcpp or iopp then
it seems to avoid all the masking
business
uh so it's not clear kind of what
happens in that case
for for the um kind of zero knowledge
part right because kind of
the outer proof system which
i guess in your example is not zero
knowledge
i mean you're sending the oracles they
really are there
so you're right um
right now you can consider some weak
notion of their knowledge that maybe you
can then
make up for it in different ways but
you know this type of composition is not
super nice
for zero knowledge right yeah i agree
with
mutants
now again you know there are other
natural properties of zero knowledge
that are preserved in proof composition
and robustification it's something that
in some earlier iterations of the purple
we were actually using
then we didn't end up using them but
they're so cute and natural that we
stash them in appendix somewhere but
they're definitely look very interesting
uh so you can ask you know in standard
sort of proof composition of outer and
inner or
standard specification iop what happens
if either of the components have a zero
knowledge property what happens to the
to the resulting thing and uh turns out
that you know the
natural definitions of for the
ingredients lead to natural
sort of conclusions in the output and so
that's something that we
you can rather carefully in into
appendices
okay thanks
um i i have a question to jonathan and
alessandro
about the the polynomials you use when
you use this demo
um i'm trying to understand why you need
the degree to be
that big like how many variables do you
have in a polynomial like
we know about would it not be possible
to sort of
bump up the number of of uh variables
and to just basically lower the degree
of the polynomial
and then still be able to apply for
example without carrying
right so the the issue there is that
that part of the argument
um if you think about how various
different shuffle arguments work
if you want to show that one collection
of n elements is like a permutation of
another n
you can show that like um some degree n
polynomial
which has you know elements on the left
hand side as roots
um also has like the same roots
um which elements on the right hand side
and then you show that kind of
one set is like a permutation of the
other um
so we use we have polynomials which um
which look something a bit like what you
see in in the shuffle arguments
um um we have a you know more concretely
like a lookup protocol which uses
polynomials of this type
um so we have a degree like a degree n
polynomial in
one variable for example um
and i'm not like um i'm not aware of
like
uh any strategy for example for like
permutation arguments which will lower
the degree of the polynomial
but still give you nice properties like
um you know um
um a polynomial you know
sorry which will still say something
about like you know the roots of the
polynomial
on the left-hand side same as you know
we have the same values as the roots on
the right hand side like both
corresponding to the same polynomial
i just don't know how to do that with
like more variables and like a lower
degree
okay i see thank you very much thanks
any more questions
um great so i think uh
uh so uh thanks to both benedict and
jonathan for a great
pair of talks this morning also thank
you very much for the
live attendees for the excellent
questions and uh
and interesting interactions so now
there's a break and will resume
in 55 minutes for the two
afternoon talks and talk to you later
you